vous le savez depuis jeudi dernier
depuis un papier d'isabelle h et dans la
presse
on parle beaucoup de liberté
d'expression de liberté académique au
sein des campus universitaires pourquoi
parce qu'une professeur à l'université
d'ottawa a utilisé un mot cistes à
connotation donc très chargée dans l'os
dans le cadre d'un cours papa comme une
insulte
elle s'appelle veruschka lieutenant
duval elle est avec nous voilà
maintenant duval merci d'être avec nous
d'abord merci de l'invitation
ça a été ça a été un dix jours
absolument horrible pour vous là oui je
vais vous avouer que je suis passé
vraiment par trois sortes d'émotions
d'ailleurs si vous me le permettez
j'aimerais de nouveaux d'ailleurs donné
mes excuses mais plus 500 excuses aux
membres de la communauté noire ou à
toute autre personne que ma mention de
ce mot en classe évidemment que je dis
dans un cadre académique une
présentation d'une théorie aurait pu
blesser ou offusqué de quelque façon que
ce soit c'était vraiment pour mon
intention c'était pas mon intention non
plus d'attirer l'attention ou de créer
une réaction vraiment peur alors oui je
suis suis bouleversée de la réaction
donc de ce que ça l'entraîné gelé j'en
suis vraiment désolé oui à fait votre
intention était totalement linverse
parce que vous étiez en train
d'expliquer que certains mots il ya des
communautés qui font du judo avec ces
mots là et qui transforme le sens et
qu'il utilise donc différemment que
l'utilisation premières qui étaient dans
ce cas là une insulte alors vous ne vous
n'aviez jamais le l'objectif de choquer
qui que ce soit ou non tout à fait
écouter j'avais dans ce col de sencours
qui porte sur l'arrêt le genre j'ai un
volet mais nous où je parle des artistes
qu'un américain en fait dans leurs
oeuvres ont répondu aux voies rapides
mais aussi à l'interdiction fait de
différentes discriminations liées au
fait au genre est à l'origine ethnique
ou et et oui c'est mon objectif c'est
justement d'aborder ces questions le
pouvoir contribuer à faire changer les
choses
oui et non mon intention était
absolument folle de d'injurier qui que
ce soit vous avez vous avez bien compris
en posant des questions de cette façon
bon vous avez étudié diverses concordia
vous connaissez bien le milieu
universitaire vous avez vu monter comme
d'autres c'est cette nouvelle façon de
faire au nom de la justice on tombe
parfois dans l'intolérance est ce que
vous êtes si étonné que ça compte tenu
du fait que vous êtes ça fait depuis
plusieurs années que vous êtes dans le
milieu universitaire vous voyez ce
courant qui est venue des états unis où
il ya des mots interdits où on scrute ce
que disent les professeurs parce que
c'est pas extrêmement inquiète en
flammes
mais vous avez raison ça fait vraiment
longtemps que je suis dans le milieu
universitaire mais vous savez quand on
est aux deux stars has u2 les premiers
encore là on n'est pas beaucoup à
l'université moi j'étais plus loin dans
mon bureau chez moi isolé essayant dans
ce qui se passe dans mon dos dans le cas
de mon deuxième des doctorats alors oui
je sais j'ai entendu ce qui se passait
mais le vous dire que j'étais
actuellement le coup prend la 2 de cette
montée jeu ce serait être comment dire
j'étais pas tant au courant mais est ce
que en fait ce que je trouve performant
sais pas c'est pas le fait que des
personnes des jeunes se lèvent contre
les discriminations les intolérants sol
je suis absolument faire je suis aussi
pour pour pour ces mouvements ce qui
m'inquiète moi c'est beaucoup plus la
violence la réponse sur les médias
sociaux
vous savez dans mon coeur est ce que ce
qui est à l'origine d'un contrevient
sont fait la publication d'un échange
courriel privé en moyenne monte et où
elle est en fait bien un extrait
complètement hors contexte en publiant
mon nom numéro de téléphone et mon
adresse et là c'est la réponse la
violence des des commentaires de
personnes qui étaient même pas dans le
court est complètement hors contexte ce
soit moi qui me qui m'inquiète beaucoup
de cesser de répondre à ce qu'on croit
être une injustice ou ce qu'on croit
être l'artiste avec des injures avec la
cispi cette violence verbale dans la
plupart des cas mais on a vu en france
violence qui peut se faire aussi très
concrète qui aidé un barbarisme 100 mo
alors c'est sa main qui marque qui
m'inquiète c'est pas la levée contre les
injustices mais bien certains certaines
dérives dans cette heure
dans ce flou dans ce mouvement parce que
dans tous les mouvements en fer qui
combattent les inégalités mais tant
qu'on tombe dans la violence et aux
envers ben que physique je jeu en
diverses et ces gens là tombent dans la
violence verbale alors qu'ils disent
vouloir protéger la justice a lancé là
où ça devient un grand grand grand
dérapage pour des gens qui sont dans des
lieux où on devrait permettre le savoir
et la libre expression est ce que vous
vous êtes donc vraiment vous nous dites
ce soir senti menacé
oui certains je me sentis menacés depuis
la première journée donc j'ai vu que mes
informations personnelles avaient été
publiées pour les médias sociaux
oui certainement je me sens menacé et
j'espère aujourd'hui par mon témoignage
d'essayer de nuancer défi de remettre en
perspective ce qui se passait raconte
après un des deux patients cia recentrer
le débat
l'enjeu principal qui à mon avis les
arts en fête des mots sensibles dans un
cadre universitaire pas d'insulter sa
d'insulter quelqu'un je suis entièrement
d accord je pense que tout le monde et
ils ont de leur côté là mais de vraiment
avec quelqu'un parce que je vous avoue
c'est pas clair moi on n'a pas
d'information claire sur quels mots quel
objet n'est pas enseignée en classe
c'est moi si j'avais su je voulais faire
on n'aurait pas eu vite fait ma part que
mon objectif c'est pas de rendre mal à
l'aise mais étudiants c'est plutôt way
de le faire en sorte qu'ils sont
contents de contenter ses sécuritaire en
fait pour aborder toutes les questions
mais l'universitaire pas été capable de
me répondre sur quel monde ne pas
utiliser sa race et ambiguïté pas de
liste qui existe et je vais vous avouer
que quand j'ai posé la question à ceux
qui s'occupent de la diversité et
d'inclusion
on a longtemps laissé entendre que dans
mon cours sur l'art autochtone mais
peut-être serait mieux de trouver le mot
qui commence à y alors je pose la
question jusqu'où ça va jusqu'où ça va
aller
c'est ça exactement dans son tout pour
ce moment il fait partie d'une loi des
plus forts alors comment je fais il
faudrait poser les questions il faudrait
mettre des balises sur sur coiffage
arrive pour les gens comprennent pas
c'est que on vous a dit n'utilise pas le
mot indien même si la loi
oui tout à fait là encore comme ça ouais
mais là on man et le ridicule vos tués
mais est ce que est ce que dans vos
prochains cours donc vous n'allez plus
jamais l'utiliser vous allez vous sentir
vous allez vous sentir extrêmement
fragile face à certains bons oui je vais
prendre beaucoup de précautions je me
suis engagé à le faire d'ailleurs auprès
de l'université d'ottawa et prennent les
étudiants de prendre encore plus de
précautions
c'est quand que le moment et nuit je ne
l'utiliserai plus j'ai malheureusement
aussi choisi parce que je constate c'est
trop sensible et c'est trop risqué de
enlevé de mon corpus les oeuvres
africaine américaine que j'avais abordé
je suis vraiment désolé mais étudiants
le sable quand j'ai retenu concours
danseurs
en communication ils ont vu mon émotion
et dont été absolument fantastique pour
pour m'expliquer qu'il comprenait qu'il
acceptait mes excuses mais mais oui je
vous le disais j'ai eu je vais faire
extrêmement attention parce que c'est
ces deux choses avant de vous laisser
tranquille 2 2
est ce qu est ce que le recteur vous
appelez vous a parlé avez vous eu des
conversations avec les autorités de
l'université d'ottawa vous ont-ils
appelé pour vous soutenir ou pour
pouvoir comment vous alliez ou poser
quelques questions que ce soit en fait
j'ai été très très soutenu par mon 5 1
dès le départ ils se sont vraiment
occupé de moi
le recteur ne ment jamais contacté que
ce soit par écrit ou par par part
comment dire en personne par téléphone
pardon j'ai communiqué avec le doyen de
la faculté des arts est une personne
madame bénir la diversité et de
l'inclusion hockey la direction joue pas
beaucoup et il avait perdu un communiqué
comme de quoi que j'étais suspendu avec
salaire mais c'est à peu près la seule
que j'ai eu et j'ai eu en a une
une rencontre en fait pour discuter de
tout était préparé mais péter april une
mère fille se sont positionnés sur
twitter en affirmant que j'avais eu un
vocabulaire est ce que est ce que vous
étudiants vous ont soutenu s que
l'ensemble de vous utilisez vous chez
nous j'en ai plein dans ce rapport là
est ce que vous avez pu évaluer ça dois
avouer que j'ai reçu énormément de
messages de soutien
bon pas de l'étudiant que j ce sens que
d'étudiants que j'ai eu deux défaites en
partie n'ai pas eu beaucoup de contact
avec mes étudiants du cours et argent
qui m'a été en fait qui a été scindé en
deux
deux groupes mais dans mon cours de
communication la majorité m'ont soutenu
et vous savez l'accueil que j'ai eu
quand j'ai pas donné mon corps vendredi
ça a été je n'oublierai jamais ce moment
de toute ma vie était extraordinaire
l'énergie positive qui avait il même je
vais vous dire que j'ai plusieurs
étudiants neurones un peu loupé le et
qui m'ont qui m'ont dit qu'ils avaient
compris qu'ils acceptaient mes excuses
qu'ils savaient que j'avais absolument
plus longtemps sont négatifs et il ya
beaucoup de citoyens noirs qui vous ont
dit vous aviez même pas vous excuser
aussi là il ya beaucoup jacques celle à
l'antenne ou parler de dire ne pas
s'excuser on doit pas interdire un mot
c'est le contexte qui est important on
ne doit pas insulter mais le contexte
fait froid de tout bon je vous laisse
aller merci de nous avoir parlé
j'imagine ça vous a fait un bond quand
même quelque chose qui vous a rassuré
sur la société
quand vous avez vu tous ces gens prendre
la parole la classe politique est
d'autant disant attention là il faut
soutenir la liberté académique la
liberté de parole oui et ce qui me
rassure aussi c'est l'entrevue la
ministre mais cannes c'est après c'est
un sommet dit je crois qui abordait
aussi la question que en fait on aurait
besoin d'engager plus de preuves venant
de la diversité dont des personnes
noires et qu'on commençait vraiment à
resserrer de nouveau le débat sur la
question
ça ça m'a aussi beaucoup de copains
encourager parce que celui-ci 1 mais
objectif en parler enfin publiquement
veruschka du lieutenant duval
professeurs chargés de convercité
d'ottawa merci beaucoup de nous avons
parlé merci au revoir